my channel is sponsored by surfshoc VPN
which means I'll have an ad from them
somewhere in the middle of this video
after spending seven real human hours
flying to Pluto I took the obvious next
step and tried to figure out how to fly
to one of starfield's many sons Stars so
if flying from Pluto's orbit to Pluto
took me seven hours someone calculated
that flying from the planet closest to
the Sun to the Sun in the soul system
would take nine years
nine human years which did I contemplate
it yes it's like okay how would I
feasibly play the game for nine straight
years so that wasn't really an option so
how was I supposed to test what it would
look like to fly into a sun in Starfield
find out if it was even possible I tried
looking at other solar systems ones that
had much bigger Stars seeing if it might
be possible to fly to their sons
ultimately no matter what the suns are
just too damn far away which obviously
is realistic also sorry if you can hear
my dog chewing on a bone
he's a good boy so I registered that I
would need to use console commands for
players who aren't aware these aren't
exactly mods I don't consider them mods
some people do it's something that
Bethesda has always provided effectively
if you're playing on PC and you hit the
tilde key
you can speed up Playa movement speed
and you can also jump hours ahead which
is what I first attempted to do it was
awful I actually don't know why this was
happening uh but often I would just flip
and spin
oh my God this is hell
I can't it's broken hang on
can I just what if I go photo mode
oh my god dude
as a fun aside here for some reason when
I was initially attempting to do this
the speed of my ship would just drop to
like four in one instance it actually
started to move in Reverse despite the
fact that I had never input anything
that would tell the ship to slow down if
anyone happens to know why that was
happening I would love if you could tell
me so I gave up on that
um in fact I assumed that using
increased player speed and skipping time
was leading me to the conclusion that I
was not able to access the Suns so those
attempts failed but I really didn't want
to give up I wanted to know if the suns
were actually there were they just fake
light sources that you could never
access I effectively used a mod now to
be clear just because I think people
like get confused about the terminology
of that the mod in this instance allowed
me to move faster in a way that I
wouldn't you know spin but it didn't
actually modify the base game so people
weren't adding in extra stuff to the
game the stuff that was that was already
there they were just allowing the ship
to move faster the code that I put into
the console commands is not like like
what I'm telling you is that a player
hasn't created
a son they just created the ability for
me to move at a reasonable Pace inside
of star Fields already existing systems
and what I found I really really did not
expect I did not think
this would be it and I'll show you but
it really leads me to believe that they
really seriously considered making this
game very differently and then changed
their minds at the last minute it's time
to talk about surfsharkvpn the sponsor
of today's video surfsharkvpn is a
virtual private Network that keeps your
online identity safe if you aren't
already familiar they basically work by
encrypting all of the information that
you send to the internet it keeps your
personal data protected from companies
and criminals but there are also some
like very personal appealing uses
outside of security which is obviously
extremely important surfsharkvpn allows
you to virtually change which country
you're in I personally do this very
frequently in order to watch Premier
League football games they are so easy
to watch if you live in the UK not so
easy to watch in any other country in
the world and if you're in different
places you have to figure out where
they're airing if they're airing what
channel what subscription you need with
surfsharkvpn you don't have to do any of
that nonsense one that I think it's huge
for gamers that you can actually stop
isps from throttling your data isps can
analyze your data and limit your
bandwidth when you're doing very data
intensive activities which seems so
unfair considering you're paying for it
but alas they don't care online games
can be pretty bad with intensive
activities so if you're using a VPN the
ISP loses the ability to mess with your
data giving you the speed you deserve
and frankly the one you're probably
paying for so if you want to protect
yourself today as you should enter promo
code Alana a-l-a-n-a-h for an extra
three months free at the link in the
description now back to the video
thank you
oh my God
I was starting to think this would never
show up
um I've been doing this for so long okay
so we just
at this point
just keep going I guess but how I've
really thought that when I got there it
was just going to be a light source like
just a glowing
or light source but it's got like
fire effects on it
like it actually has solar flare coming
off of it why have they done that oh my
gosh okay um I'm gonna hide myself again
go back to hitting boost for another I
don't know how long we've got I've been
doing this for over an hour
it'll be a while
uh and I'll jump back in when it's like
up close how exciting
me once again
went through it we went through
the Sun
why does it have fire effects on the
outside hang on let me slow down a
little bit dude
um yeah Unlike Pluto week because of the
the like solar flare effects we can
actually see them
well you can hear it a little why
so oh my gosh and I really dipped
through it so fast now I gotta want to
jump back out though so let me see if I
can just uh hang on speed up again so I
can go back out there we go okay I'm out
I'm out I'm out why does it exist
and it's so big am I gonna go back
inside again no I think it's gonna
overtake me because it's moving even
faster than I am
gosh soda low resist we get closer with
those solar flare effects looked awesome
from a really really long distance my
guess is that initially you would have
burnt up trying to get closer to it and
there was like a distance where you
would be able to see it but as you came
closer you would burn up oh is that
because I'm entering again not trying to
this this has to have been built this
way because they initially intended for
us to fly between planets it doesn't
make any sense why you would do this in
any other context why are any of the
planets accessible
why does it have solar flares mapped on
the outside of it like because really
all you actually have to do is what I've
done here which is
speed up
your ship that's all you actually have
to do to travel between planets and it
works just fine you still can't land or
anything and obviously I just like
walked through it again but the travel
pot which I would have thought was like
very intensive I mean obviously it's
huge we're kind of losing a bit of the
sense of the scale because of uh the
speed like I've traveled very very fast
to get away from it even by this much
which is why it doesn't look as big as
it should let me slow down and see what
that does to our perception of the scale
of the thing we are now at regular speed
interesting that it's not costing light
either like it isn't costing any light
on the ship
obviously like you could see where it's
connected together it's how the solar
flare should actually look when they
aren't just like super sped up damn dude
the sun is fully here fully realized has
to have been for a reason a team
wouldn't just waste resources to do this
and create that solar flare tech for no
reason that would make any sense well
now my question is
can we travel between systems
that's got to be the next test right
like that's that'll take even longer if
this as fast as possible still took me
over an hour of manually hitting boost
like if I try and get to Alpha Centauri
which is obviously what I'm gonna do
it'll take a long time but I want to
know if it's possible
so because we just jumped from Mercury
to the sun
um we have now effectively confirmed
that you can travel between planets like
you you can't just travel from Pluto's
orbit to Pluto you can travel from
Mercury to Seoul which is effectively a
separate Planet meaning that I would be
able to travel from
earth to Venus so Uranus to Venus or
whatever like that would actually be
possible how cool and also confusing
this is just giving me so many more
questions why have you done this so
after about an hour I got to the Sun and
yeah I'm sure this is all in my reaction
but was like very impressed by the solar
flares very impressed by the fact that
it exists and is moving and maybe has a
sound that seems to be audio and
ultimately it confirmed to me that there
is an earlier version of Starfield that
exists where you were able to travel
between planets in fact I think Todd may
have even said that I think they may
have said something along the lines of
like yeah we thought about letting you
travel between planets and decided it
wasn't very fun and to be fair me
sitting here and smashing shift to boost
to get up my um speed correctly was not
very fun by choice I would not do that
again I would be using the menus and
shortcuts so as for how I did this uh I
found a fix after playing around with it
myself and clearly not doing things
right on Nexus mods um the post is from
music called helxis I will leave a link
in the description to where you can find
it directly but this person has
basically created
um four separate speeds for the ship
there's a cruise a super cruise and
a hyper cruise and I was using hyper
cruise for this and also speeding up
game time so I sped up game time to
probably like plus 20 including using
his uh hyper Cruise so I'll leave a link
in the description if you want to check
it out yourself obviously PC only not
technically a mod in that you don't have
to download or install anything you just
have to input the text into the console
commands which is awesome but yes I
found this really fun and I do think my
next experiment has got to be seeing if
we can travel between systems I think it
will take a really really really long
time so I might have to do that one on
stream again but hopefully you found
this video informative or interesting in
some way I was so excited to find this
at the end of it because I've been
asking this question so often like what
what happens if you try to fly to the
sun it's one of the first things I want
to do which is too goddamn far away to
do it without putting in useful console
commands so thank you for watching I'm
Alana I hope you are as excited by this
discovery as I am for some reason
we'll see y'all next time bye